ANOTHER BRUISING DAY BEFORE
CONGRESS FOR SECRETARY STATE
ANTONY BLINKEN THE SENATE PANEL
DRILLING HIM FOR ANSWERS ABOUT
THE BOTCHED WITHDRAW FROM
AFGHANISTAN BECAUSE SO FAR THE
BIDEN ADMINISTRATION REFUSED TO
SAY IT DID ANYTHING WRONG,
REPUBLICANS NOT MINCING WORDS.
>> YOU WON'T.
THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION CAUSED
THIS DISASTER.
>> THIS IS A COMPLETE DEBACLE.
>> WE HAD EVERY REASON TO
BELIEVE AND TO PLAN FOR THE
RAPID COLLAPSE OF THE AFGAN
MILITARY AND THE OF A BEGAN
GOVERNMENT.
>> PRESIDENT BIDEN HAS DESCRIBED
THE EVACUATION FROM AFGHANISTAN
AS AN EXTRAORDINARY SUCCESS.
THIS HAS TO BE THE LIE OF THE
21ST CENTURY.
>> THINGS GOT REALLY HEATED WHEN
SENATOR TED CRUZ PRESSURED
WHETHER THE OFFICIALS GAVE THE
TALIBAN THE NAMES OF AMERICAN
CITIZENS DURING THE CHAOTIC
EVACUATION.
>> DID THE STATE DEPARTMENT GIVE
THE TALIBAN A LIST OR MULTIPLE
LISTS OF AMERICANS AND/OR AFGANS
THAT WE WANTED OUT?
>> THOSE REPORTS AND THE IDEA
THAT WE WOULD DO ANYTHING TO
ENDANGER OUR CITIZENS OR ANYONE
ELSE AT A TIME WHEN WE'RE TRYING
TO SAVE THEIR LIVES IS FLAT-OUT
WRONG.
IN LIMITED INSTANCES WHERE WE
WERE SEEKING TO GET A BUS OR A
GROUP OF PEOPLE THROUGH A CHECK
POINT, WE GAVE A MANIFEST TO THE
PEOPLE AT THE CHECK POINT TO
DEMONSTRATE THAT THOSE PEOPLE
WERE EXPECTED --
>> ROUGHLY HOW MANY NAMES WERE
ON THE LIST YOU GAVE?
>> DOESN'T MATTER BECAUSE
THEY --
>> DOZENS?
HUNDREDS?
THOUSANDS.
GIVE US A MAGNITUDE.
>> THIS HAPPENED IN --
>> IT'S YOUR TESTIMONY IT WASN'T
HUNDREDS, DID YOU GIVE THEM
THOUSANDS?
>> NO, ABSOLUTELY NOT.
>> Dana: ONE OF THE THINGS
SENATOR RON JOHNSON SAID TO
BLINKEN IS THERE'S FRUSTRATION
THAT IT FEELS THE ADMINISTRATION
IS DETACHED FROM THE SITUATION
>> Jesse: HE DID AN OKAY JOB BUT
THE REPUBLICANS WERE FOCUSED WAY
TOO MUCH ON SOUND BITES THAT
THEY CAN PUSH OUT TO DONORS AND
ON SOCIAL MEDIA.
THIS HEARING NEEDS TO BE ABOUT
ESTABLISHING A PATTERN OF FACTS,
A TIME LINE, AND GETTING DIRECT
TESTIMONY ON THE RECORD.
WHEN DID YOU KNOW, AND WHAT DID
YOU KNOW AND WHEN DID YOU KNOW
IT?
AND THEN YOU CAN PRESENT THAT
EVIDENCE TO THE AMERICAN PEOPLE,
AND THAT'S HOW YOU GET TO THE
TRUTH AND ACCOUNTABILITY.
KABUL DID NOT FALL IN 11 DAYS,
DANA.
THAT IS A LIE.
IT TOOK MONTHS FOR THE AFGAN
ARMY TO DESERT AND SURRENDER.
THE TALIBAN TAKEOVER CAME AFTER
THREE MONTHS.
BIDEN WAS BRIEFED BY THE
INTELLIGENCE AGENCIES, STATE
DEPARTMENT CABLES WENT OUT,
EMBASSY CABLES WENT OUT.
BIDEN KNEW IN JULY THAT THE
TALIBAN WAS TAKING OVER BECAUSE
HE GOT ON THE PHONE CALL WITH
THE AFGAN PRESIDENT AND SAID LIE
FOR ME.
MAKE SURE IT LOOKS BETTER ON THE
GROUND SO I GET HELP POLITICALLY
AND THEN MAYBE I'LL GIVE YOU A
LITTLE MORE AIR SUPPORT.
SO THE LIES COST LIVES, AND WE
NEED TO KNOW THE FACTS.
SO AL KADE A'S BACK IN
AFGHANISTAN AND WE HAVE DEAD
MARINES AND WE HAVE A HUGE
TECHNOLOGY TRANSFER TO THE
CHINESE MILITARY WHICH WE'RE
GOING TO HAVE TO DEAL WITH IN
THE PACIFIC AND NOW WE'RE
IMPORTING ALL THESE CHILD
BRIDES.
WE'RE BRINGING IN THOUSANDS OF
AFGAN MEN WHO MARRIED 12 YEARS
OLD, CREWS GOT INTO THAT, WHERE
WILL THEY LIVE DANA?
IN AMERICA THEY'RE CALLED CHILD
MOLESTERS.
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO LIVE IN
ANTONY BLINKEN'S NEIGHBORHOOD SO
WHAT DO WE DO WITH THEM?
IF THIS WAS A REPUBLICAN
PRESIDENT HE'D ALREADY HAVE
IMPEACHMENT HEARINGS.
THEY GO AFTER THESE HEARINGS
LIKE LITIGATEERS IN A HOMICIDE
TRIAL.
REPUBLICANS ACT LIKE IT'S DEBATE
CLUB.
NO.
WE WANT ANTSES, WE DESERVE
ANSWERS AND WE'RE NOT GOING TO
GET IT IF YOU BEAT AROUND THE
BUSH.
>> MANY TIMES THESE HEARINGS
FEEL PERFORMATIVE NOT
PRODUCTIVE.
ON THE HOUSE SIDE THEY HAD 3-5
MINUTES AND ON THE SENATE SIDE
THEY HAVE SEVEN SO THERE'S
BENEFITS I GUESS TO BEING A
SENATOR.
BUT THERE WAS SOMETHING FROM
SENATOR BOB MENENDEZ IN TERMS OF
HIS FRUSTRATION AS THE OVERSIGHT
CHAIRMAN.
WATCH.
>> THE EXECUTION OF THE U.S.
WITHDRAW WAS CLEARLY AND FATALLY
FLAWED.
THIS COMMITTEE EXPECTS TO
RECEIVE A FULL EXPLANATION OF
THE ADMINISTRATION'S DECISIONS
ON AFGHANISTAN SINCE COMING INTO
OFFICE LAST JANUARY.
THERE HAS TO BE ACCOUNTABILITY.
>> I WANT TO GET YOUR TAKE ON
SOMETHING.
SO LLOYD AUSTIN WOULD NOT
TESTIFY TODAY, SECRETARY OF
DEFENSE.
THEY SAID HE'S GOING TO BE
TESTIFYING IN FRONT OF ANOTHER
COMMITTEE LATER THIS MONTH.
THERE'S SOME FRUSTRATION FROM
PEOPLE WHO FOLLOW THIS THAT THIS
IS JUST ALL BEING DONE IN A
PIECEMEAL WAY AND THEY WOULD
LIKE TO HAVE LIKE THE 9/11
COMMISSION.
IS THAT SOMETHING THE DEMOCRATS
WOULD BE WILLING TO DO.
>> I ACTUALLY DO THINK IT'S
SOMETHING DEMOCRATS WOULD BE
WILLING TO DO.
BOB MENENDEZ IS A STRONG BIDEN
SUPPORTER.
THIS IS SOMEONE, HE BACKED BIDEN
IN 2016 WHEN HILLARY ENDED UP
BEING THE NOMINEE AND HIS WORDS
WERE AS FORCEFUL AS TED CRUZ'S
OR RON JOHNSON AND YESTERDAY WE
SAW IT FROM KEY FIGURES IN THE
DEMOCRATIC HOUSE LIKE KAREN
BASS.
AND I THINK THAT IT IS GOING TO
CONTINUE.
I DO THINK ON AN OPTICS LEVEL IT
MADE A BIG DIFFERENCE THAT
SECRETARY BLINKEN WAS IN PERSON
TODAY.
NOT THAT IT WAS HIS FAULT FOR
NOT GOING YESTERDAY, WAS THE
RULES THAT YOU COULD ZOOM IN.
THERE WAS EVEN THE CONGRESSMAN
WHO WAS IN HIS CLOSET WHO DID
IT.
BUT YOU SHOULD BE THERE.
THIS IS A BIG DEAL AND WILL BE
AS LEON PANETTA SAID IT.
A HUGE MOMENT IN HIS TIME AS
SECRETARY OF STATE, FOR BETTER
OR FOR WORSE AND I DID LIKE THE
DYNAMICS BETTER IN PERSON.
IT NEEDS TO BE TREATED WITH
RESPECT ESPECIALLY SINCE WE LOST
AMERICAN LIVES, 13, AND 18
WOUNDED.
BUT IT FELT LIKE A BIPARTISAN
SHELLACKING TO ME.
IT FELT LIKE YESTERDAY WAS
LONGER TIME LIMITS.
AND I THINK THAT THAT'S
SOMETHING THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION IS PREPARED FOR.
THEY KNOW WHAT THE POLLING LOOKS
LIKE ON THIS AND THEY'RE GOING
TO SHOW UP AND THEY'RE GOING TO
TAKE IT.
>> Dana: KATIE ONE OF THE THINGS
THAT FRUSTRATED SOME OF THE
PEOPLE WORKING BEHIND THE
SCENES, THESE PRIVATE GROUPS
WORKING WITH VETERANS WHO ARE
TRYING THE ON GET THERE,
INTERPRETERS AND THEIR FAMILIES
OUT, WAS WHEN ANTONY BLINKEN
SAID, EVERY ONE OF THE PEOPLE,
AND I GUESS HE WAS TALKING ABOUT
THE AMERICANS THAT ARE LEFT
BEHIND AND THE GREEN CARD
HOLDERS, HAS BEEN ASSIGNED A
CASE WORKER.
>> RIGHT.
>> Dana: CASE MANAGER AND THEY
HAVE A TEAM OF CASE MANAGERS AND
ONE OF THE YOUNG WOMEN I TALKED
TO SAID THAT CAN'T BE TRUE.
SHE SAID IF IT IS TRUE THEN ALL
THESE MESSAGES I'M GETTING ARE
PEOPLE WHO JUST CAN'T GET
ANYBODY TO RETURN THEIR CALLS AT
THE STATE DEPARTMENT.
>> THE STATE DEPARTMENT HAS KIND
OF TRIED TO TAKE CREDIT FOR THE
PRIVATE GROUP AND ORGANIZATIONS
THAT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO GET
PEOPLE OUT WHEN THE GOVERNMENT
HAS FAILED TO DO SO.
AND WHEN THE SECRETARY OF STATE
WAS ASKED IF THE STATE
DEPARTMENT, YOU KNOW, DIDN'T
ALLOW CERTAIN FLIGHTS TO TAKE
OFF, IF THEY WERE DENYING PEOPLE
ACCESS TO THE AIRPORT, THE
ANSWER FROM THE SECRETARY OF
STATE WAS NO, WHEN WE KNOW FROM
TALKING TO A NUMBER OF PEOPLE
AND FROM CO-ERSING THAT THEY
WERE DENYING FLIGHTS TAKING OFF,
THEY WERE DENYING PEOPLE COMING
INTO THE AIRPORT AND THEY WERE
TELLING PEOPLE TO COME TO THE
AIRPORT WHEN THEY COULDN'T GET
THERE BECAUSE THE TALIBAN WASN'T
LETTING THEM THROUGH, FOR WEEKS
ON END.
THE BIPARTISAN NATURE OF THIS I
THOUGHT WAS INTERESTING, AND
BASED ON THE IDEA THAT WHEN YOU
LISTEN TO EACH OF THEM SPEAK
TODAY, AND THIS HAPPENED A LOT
YESTERDAY IN THE HOUSE, EVERY
SINGLE SENATOR AND CONGRESSMAN
HAS A STORY LINKED TO TRYING TO
GETTING SOMEBODY OUT OF
AFGHANISTAN.
AND IT IS, YOU KNOW, THE JOB OF
CONGRESSIONAL OFFICES AND
OFFICES OF THE SENATE TO HELP
GET PEOPLE HOME, BUT IT REALLY
IS THE STATE DEPARTMENT'S JOB.
AND FOR THE ADMINISTRATION UP TO
THIS POINT TO KEEP SAYING THAT
THIS WAS A SUCCESSFUL AIRLIFT,
IT WAS A SUCCESSFUL EVACUATION,
WHEN YOU HAVE SENATORS AND
CONGRESSMEN STILL GETTING PHONE
CALLS FROM AMERICANS AND SIVs
STILL STUCK?
AFGHANISTAN THAT MAKES IT CLOSER
AND THE WORK THEY'RE DOING.
>> Dana: ONE OTHER PIECE FROM
SENATOR TED CRUZ IF YOU PULL
THAT UP BECAUSE BRIAN THIS IS
ONE OF THE QUESTIONS AMERICANS
ARE GOING TO HAVE.
EXCUSE ME, IT'S RAND PAUL.
$64 BILLION?
THAT'S POSSIBLY GOING TO BE
GOING TO THE HE-TO AFGHANISTAN.
AND I'M WONDERING, DOES THAT
PASS THROUGH THE AFGAN
GOVERNMENT?
HERE'S SENATOR RAND PAUL.
>> THIS WEEK, YOU'VE NOW
RELEASED $64 MILLION IN AID TO
AFGHANISTAN.
DON'T WE HAVE SOME PROHIBITION
TO GIVING AID AND COMFORT TO THE
ENEMY?
DO WE REALLY -- ARE WE REALLY
NAIVE ENOUGH TO BELIEVE WE'RE
GOING TO CONTINUE SENDING
CHARITY TO AFGHANISTAN AND
THEY'RE NOT GOING TO INTERRUPT
IT.
I THINK THAT'S A FOOLISH NOTION.
COULD YOU PLEDGE TODAY WITHOUT
EQUIVOCATION THAT THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION WILL NOT RELEASE
ANY OF THAT MONEY TO THE
TALIBAN.
>> ABSENT THE TALIBAN MAKING
GOOD ON THE COMMITMENTS AND
EXPECTATIONS OF THE
INTERNATIONAL COMMUNITY THAT
I'VE OUTLINED PREVIOUSLY.
THAT'S CORRECT.
>> MAYBE WE COULD DEDUCT A FEE
FOR THE WEAPONS THEY TOOK.
>> ANY THOUGHTS ON THAT OR
ANYTHING ELSE.
>> 64 MILLION IS PART OF THE
1.2 BILLION WE PROMISED FOR
INTERNATIONAL AID.
TURNS OUT 18 MILLION AFGANS
DEPEND ON THE GOVERNMENT TO FOR
THEIR FOOD AND CLOTHING.
CONGRATULATIONS TALIBAN YOU HAVE
A COUNTRY TO RUN, HOT JUST
PEOPLE TO BEE HELPED, YOU HAVE
TO DO OTHER STUFF AND THEY WANT
AID.
AND THEY ALSO SAY THANK YOU VERY
MUCH BUT CAN WE HAVE MORE.
I DON'T SEE WHY WE GIVE THEM
ANYTHING BUT YOU GO AHEAD, YOU
WANT MORE.
THE BIG THING WAS OVER THE LAST
FEW DAYS IS IT'S TRUMP'S FALL
FAULT.
IT WAS TRUMP'S DEAL WE HAVE NO
CHOICE.
SO THE GUY UNDOING EVERYTHING
PRESIDENT TRUMP DOES, AND I
THINK JOE BIDEN TAKES GREAT
PRIDE IN IT, EVERYTHING TRUMP
DID HE'S UNDONE.
WHEN IT COMES TO TALIBAN, THIS
IS IRON CLAD, THIS IS THE DEAL
TRUMP HAD.
IT'S SIX PAGES, MY HEALTH CLUB
CONTRACT IS HARDER TO GET OUT OF
THAN THIS.
IT IS GENERIC AS IT GETS ANYONE
CAN GET OUT OF THIS.
YOU ALMOST WENT TO LAW SCHOOL,
YOU DID YOU WERE AT THE BOTTOM
OF YOUR SCREES.
CLASS.
SO I TEXTED MIKE POMPEO, AND HE
HAD AN IMPORTANT JOB.
HE SAID WE WOULD ONLY HAVE LEFT
ONCE ALL CONDITIONS WERE MET.
WE DIDN'T PLAN FOR CHAOS BECAUSE
WE WOULDN'T HAVE HAD IT.
WE HAD CONSTANT DETERRENT.
WE WOULD HIT THEM AS SOON AS
THEY BROKE THE AGREEMENT.
AND THE BUTCHER SAID IF YOU ANY
OF THESE PROMISES WE WILL FIND
YOU AND KILL YOU LIKE COAL
MAINY.
THAT'S WHY HE CALLED AT THE EDGE
OF KABUL AND SAID DO YOU WANT TO
TAKE IT OR DO YOU WANT ME TO
TAKE IT AND GENERAL McKENZIE
SAID WHY DON'T YOU TAKE IT I'LL
JUST TAKE THE AIRPORT.
CAN WE SAY THAT'S ONE OF THE
STUPIDIST RESPONSES TO THE
TALIBAN, AND THERE'S BEEN A LOT.
I CANNOT BE MORE FRUSTRATED
BECAUSE NOT WHAT DEMOCRAT WHAT
LIEBERMAN DID TO SENATOR BUSH,
THEY QUESTIONED WAR DECISIONS,
THEY FORGOT ABOUT PARTY.
NOBODY FORGOT WHAT PARTY THEY
WERE IN TODAY ON THE DEMOCRATIC
SIDE.
EVEN THOUGH MENENDEZ DID SAY
WE'RE GOING TO FIND OUT ABOUT
THAT, BUT THERE WAS MORE KISSING
HIS BUTT THAN CALLING HIM OUT.
>> HE CALLED IT AN ABJECT
FAILURE AND IN YOUR HEALTH CLUB
THING DOES IT ALSO SAY WE'RE
GOING TO RELEASE 5,000 TAL BANS
FOR A THOUSAND AFGANS.
>> 5,000 TO 1,000, A BAD IDEA.
ABSOLUTELY A BAD IDEA.
BUT THAT DOES NOT MEAN YOU CAN'T
BREAK IT, PUSH IT BACK AND UNDO
IT BECAUSE IT'S NOT IN AMERICA'S
IN